that's hard because the
[Music]
depends all right so let's get
started uh shanj dusa needs no
introduction uh so he's of course their
fearless leader for this this program uh
from UCSD has done uh all sorts of uh
pioneering work including in the area of
active learning and uh that's one of the
topics of the uh tutorial this
afternoon welcome s okay thank you um so
um so uh Rob Noak and I are going to be
talking about um Interactive Learning
and so I'll do the first half and Rob
will do the second half
um so the the first question is uh you
know what is this Interactive Learning
thing and uh it's it's most easily
thought of in contrast with the way
supervised learning usually happens
which is that you know a data set is is
obtained in some way uh a human being is
brought in to label all of these data
points painstakingly the human being
goes away and at some later point in
time a machine is started up given this
label data set and told to find a
classifier okay so there's no
interaction at all between the human and
the learning machine okay so um so
Interactive Learning uh refers um to
various scenarios including those in
which a in which the learning machine
interacts or engages adaptively with a
human while learning is taking place so
it's like the human and the Machine are
kind of puzzling over the data set
together okay and uh sometimes it's
actually not a human being so for
example the machine might be interacting
with a robot that is conducting
biological experiments or the machine
might be doing experiments on a network
like measuring latencies or stuff like
that okay so um so this is a vague
definition of Interactive Learning the
learning machine engages a actively with
an information source during learning it
would be nice to have a more formal
definition okay but um I don't think we
have one and uh in the absence of one
I'll just go Um I I'll just go over a
few sort of um uh examples just to just
to illustrate the range of um
Interactive Learning that takes place
okay so um so one type of Interactive
Learning that has really been studied a
lot uh perhaps the you know perhaps the
most is what's usually just called
Active Learning okay and the situation
here is that you have a very large
unlabeled data set okay maybe 100,000
documents or something and you simply
it's simply infeasible to have a human
label all of these okay it's too
expensive it's too time consuming you
know maybe you can label a thousand of
them okay uh which thousand do you pick
and in active learning this is done in
an Adaptive way okay the machine might
pick a few randomly and then after a
while say okay you know what this is the
one I want next that is the one that's
going to give me the most information
and this is the one I want next and so
on okay and so it adaptively picks a few
examples and the sort of questions that
we have in this case are what sort of
strategy should the machine follow and
um what is the trade-off we get between
the number of labels queried and the
error of the classifier is this way
better than random querying and um and
as you know so so this something we'll
talk about quite a lot and as we'll see
it is it is way better um okay and so
this is what we would usually call
Active
Learning um another kind of interaction
which uh has been studied um much less
in theory almost none at all uh would be
called explanation based learning and um
and here what happens is that the human
labels a data point but also provides an
explanation for it okay often in in the
form of features and so let me give you
an example okay so let's say um the
human is given a document to label so
the human reads through the document and
says okay you know after quickly
skimming it the human says okay this is
obviously a sports
document but now if the labeler has gone
to the trouble of actually you know
skimming the document it's almost no
additional effort to also maybe
highlight a few words that are highly
predictive of that label uh like you
know Cricket or you know batsman or
umpire or something like that okay and
so this is very little extra effort and
it could make a huge difference in terms
of you know for example feature
selection in a high dimensional
space um another example that um you
know that uh that has been tried out
quite a lot in computer vision is uh
systems where for example you know a new
picture of a bird comes up the computer
looks at it and says oh this yellow bird
I think it's a canary okay and then ask
the human am I right and so the human
who's a bird expert looks at it and says
no that's not that is something else
maybe a Yellow Warbler or something and
then in addition to that label also
clicks on a part of the image that
explains the difference you know for
example the beak you know clicks on the
beak okay and uh and that's a
discriminative feature okay so um so
this sort of uh this sort of explanation
based learning has really not been uh
you know uh studied a lot formally you
sort of in a in a mathematical sense but
it's uh it's very interesting and so
sort of the questions are what is the
benefit that these additional
explanations provide Beyond labels alone
okay and secondly in many of these
situations there's inherent ambiguity in
the feedback so the human is clicking on
the beak and what does that mean like
what is the feature is it the color of
the beak is it the shape of the beak is
it the fact there that there's a beak is
it the whole head actually you know like
what is the you know there's a lot of
ambiguity in this feedback and it's kind
of interesting to to figure out how to
deal with
that kind kind of interaction which I
think would be extremely useful to have
a lot more of is interaction for
unsupervised learning okay so over the
past decade or two there have been all
there's been some really amazing
progress in algorithms for unsupervised
learning okay so we have methods now
that will find um you know the
generating mixture of gaussians or the
right topic model or you know the the
optimal cine solution or whatever and
this is fantastic but at the end of the
day okay so you now have the optimal K
solution but it's still not the
clustering you actually want okay and so
and the reason for that is that you know
when you have a high dimensional data
set there are just so many different
ways you can slice or dice it you know
if you're like clustering say you know
participants of the of the Simons
program would it be according to
Geographic uh location or you know uh
academic trajectory or areas of Interest
I mean these are all very natural ways
to Cluster the data they all correspond
to salient clust ERS of people uh
they're all perfectly legitimate and
there's no way that an unsupervised
algorithm can magically know which of
these Alternatives is the one that you
actually want okay and so this is an
area that seems ripe for interaction
okay so how would that take place in the
in this um in the matter of clustering
well so let's say that the machine has
generated some clustering of say 100,000
points how could it get feedback from
the user well you can't show the use all
100,000 points and say do you like this
clustering so you know one of so one
example of the sort of things people
have tried is is to say okay well I
can't show you my full clustering but
I'm going to show you a little random
snapshot of it here's what the
clustering looks like limited to just
six points what do you think about this
and then the human says oh you know it
doesn't look quite right I don't know
exactly how to pinpoint what's wrong
with it but one thing I can definitely
tell you is that dolphin and whale have
to be together you know something like
that so you get this sort of simple
feedback or simple constraint of that
form or if it's a hierarchical
clustering you know the human again says
okay you've you've shown me the
Restriction of the hierarchy to just
these six points I can't tell you the
correct hierarchy even for those six
points cuz that's you know too difficult
for my brain but what I can definitely
tell you is that dolphin and whale
should be merged before zebra is added
in or something like that okay and so
the question is you know what are
interactive schemes of this form for um
the popular kinds of unsupervised
learning and um you know and and and how
rapidly can you converge to to the right
dog at the one that the one that you
actually want okay um so some of the
questions um that arise in these
settings is first of all of course you
know what are efficient ways to do
interaction what is the minimum amount
of interaction needed to get a um um to
arrive at a structure that is um
adequate for the human
um in many of in many situations it's
interesting to to to ask whether
interaction is actually helping to
overcome computational barriers okay is
the problem NP hard without interaction
and you know actually uh easy with
interaction um then there are um
questions about the modes of interaction
what sort of questions can you ask that
are easy for a human to answer and that
lead to Reliable feedback and you know
so this might seem like it's purely a
human computer interface kind of
question but uh but I think it's also
amenable to Theory I mean maybe not you
know mathematical Theory but theory of
in the form of um identifying um
underlying principles and reasoning
based on
those and then um I mean one of the
things that really I find most exciting
about this area is the communication gap
between the human and the Machine um in
these sorts of um interactive um
scenarios okay they um nobody knows
knows what representation the human has
we all know what representation the
machine has but we don't understand it
you know what do the nodes and the
neural net mean you know so you know how
so how can you know so labels are safe
everybody agrees on what a label means
but the minute you move to richer
interaction there is this communication
gap that has to be bridged and what are
ways of bridging it and you know what
can you show about it so these are some
of the questions that arise um in
Interactive Learning and uh what I'll be
talking about today um is is mostly the
stuff that's known um most you know
which is not that much um having to do
with uh the active learning of
classifiers and then Rob will be talking
about um richer uh classes of structures
and also about um issues that arise in
practice okay so um Active Learning okay
um so this is a a problem of um
considerable practical importance and so
there are actually lots of heuristics
for for doing Active Learning and I can
uh you know and and and the way a lot of
them work is as follows so you have this
huge data set you have to adaptively
decide which points that you're going to
query okay so the the typical way this
goes is you start by picking a few
points at random okay then just to get
the lay of the land okay and then maybe
you fit a classifier to those and then
once once you've done that then you
begin the actual intelligent querying
Loop where you say well you know what I
don't need to ask for the label of this
cuz that's probably a red okay let me
focus on the points close to the
boundary okay and so you say okay let me
ask for that one and that one and then
you get a few more labels and then you
refit the classifier and then you keep
going in this way so it's very intuitive
um makes sense you you ask for the
labels of things that you are most
uncertain about and it seems therefore
in some sort of information theoretic
sense that you know you are um you are
maximizing the amount of information you
get from each label okay so these are
very intuitive um heuristics and so you
know as theoretician the question before
us okay how do we analyze these things
these certainly make sense they seem
sensible how do we analyze them and um
sort of the default model for doing this
would probably be the statistical
learning uh theory model okay um which
says that there is some unknown
underlying distribution from what from
which all data points are generated okay
so it's a joint Distribution on data and
labels we don't know what it is but
everything comes from this distribution
we are picking a classifier from some
class H okay and we want to find the
very best thing in the class the thing
that has lowest error on that underlying
distribution now since we don't know
what the distribution is we just take a
few samples from it and then we do well
on those samples and then the
statistical Theory takes over and tells
us that as the number of samples goes to
Infinity we converge to that best
possible classifier okay so that's the
statistical learning
model so now with this sort of framework
in mind we can go back to those
heuristics and say okay well let's see
how we would think about this in the
model of statistical learning theory so
you have this fast body of unlabeled
points you pick a few of them at random
to label okay that's great the random
samples you have are genuinely random
draws from the underlying distribution
that's good now you begin your Active
Learning Loop okay so now you're
querying points near the boundary and as
time goes on you get more and more
points that are kind of filed up near
where you think the boundary
is do those look like the underlying
distribution okay and this is when you
know you start to run into some trouble
okay all of a sudden this doesn't seem
like it's necessarily such a great idea
as time goes on you are getting a set of
label points that looks less and less
like this underlying distribution P does
it really make sense to optimize with
respect to this label set are these tics
such a great idea after all okay so if
there seems to be some sort of
uh bias sampling that's going on okay
and so um so let's look at a concrete
example of the problems that this might
cause okay so here's a very simple um
scenario where the data lies on a line
so the all the data is one dimensional
okay and the sort of classifier we're
looking for is just a threshold on and
we're going to say green on this side
red on that side we're just looking for
a very simple type of classifier now the
data is clustered there's like a cluster
of red points over here a big cluster of
green points over here and so on so now
you run your Active Learning heuristic
so you pick a few points at random
question what's the 5% so it's what's a
5% doing on the left yeah so this is
this is 5% green these are 5% of points
of which half are red and half are green
wait but you're class red means the the
two labels are red and green but you
said the label is based on a threshold
so I'm yeah so right so the classifier
we're looking for is um there's nothing
that has zero error oh it's not okay so
yeah so um so now um so let's see what
happens you pick a few points at random
they'll probably be from these extrnal
clusters since that's where most of the
data lies so you get a few Reds a few
greens and so your initial boundary will
be somewhere in the middle over here now
based on that the points you're going to
query are going to be points from the
middle all the points that you see will
reinforce your belief that this is the
boundary you're looking for and so this
is the boundary you're going to converge
to but it's a boundary that has 5% error
whereas if you put the boundary over
here you would just have 2 and 1 half%
error okay so forget about using labels
efficiently in this situation even if
you had infinitely many labels you would
converge to the wrong thing okay so um
it's so these methods lack statistical
consistency which is like a very basic
uh thing that we hope for from uh
learning methods yeah can you have this
problem with the optimum solution is
zero error yeah so then it will go away
right so this is in the more General
separable case
right okay so um so so you know so one
of the basic challenges in active
learning is dealing with bias sampling
you're creating a bias sample how do you
manage this in such a way that you can
at least guarantee consistency you know
that's a very basic requirement and um
after that you can worry about
optimizing the number of labels yeah so
I don't think you can get around this
because if you look at the hardness
results I think you know some queries
won't tell you anything like they're PCB
based so basically have to query a lot
to get any
ideas so I'm just saying this is
inherent put on the line oh I don't know
about the line but for linear no linear
in one dimension you can do with one of
the Epsilon samples without active not
one dimension High dimensional you'll
see plenty of positive results sorry
we'll see plenty of positive results
pretty
soon but this problem will remain thing
right so the problem of I mean so the
problem of finding say the best hyper
plane right is of course NP
hard yeah even yeah if it's not yeah but
this is sort of an uh this is sort of an
orthogonal problem that can be solved
which is just it can be solved so I'm
actually suggesting it's hard okay um
well we'll see we'll see um in a little
bit okay so so one interesting question
over here is there is there a generic
fix to these heuristics that just makes
them consistent okay so forget about you
know efficient uh use of labels you know
all these uncertainty based teristics is
there some generic thing you can do to
them maybe it's a little bit of random
sampling or something that just
automatically makes them consistent I
don't know that would be really nice
yeah isn't this the same kind of like
exploration versus exploitation issue
that comes up so often in all sorts of
different areas yeah so this is an
exploration versus exploitation issue in
the sense that in this case you don't
see any points from this cluster and yet
from the get-go you're confident that
everything here is red okay so you you
know and so um and so this is misplaced
confidence and so with better um you
know with with um with better confidence
bounds you would you know you you would
be able to avoid this with a little bit
of exploration which would require a
little bit of
exploration okay so um okay so so just
adopting the statistical learning
framework already gave us insight into
these heuristics and the next form of
insight that the model brings is just to
try and understand what kind of benefits
do we expect from Active Learning okay
so it's it's clearly non-trivial you
know even to get consistency but what
kind of benefits do we expect over
random sampling okay and the canonical
example for that is again uh points on
the line okay so let's say now that we
are actually in the separable case and
that what we're looking for is a
threshold on the line and everything to
the right is going to be plus everything
to the left is going to be minus okay so
we're just looking for one number and we
know from generalization theory that if
you want um error Epsilon you need about
one over Epsilon labeled points because
if you have one over Epsilon points then
the distance between consecutive points
is a the probability Mass between
consecutive points is about Epsilon and
so you can estimate with um you can
estimate the right threshold within an
error of Epsilon okay so this is how
much we need for supervised learning
instead you can start with one over
Epsilon unlabeled points and then you do
binary search you ask for the label of
the middle one if it turns out to be
green then you ask for the label of the
25 percentile point and so on and in
this way the number of labels you need
is just log 1 over Epsilon and there
aren't any hidden constants here e
either you know so it's the the
Improvement is dramatic it's from 1
Epsilon to log 1 over Epsilon
okay so this is um this is why we're
hopeful um and so the question is what
happens what happens when we take this
same reasoning to other hypothesis
classes okay so now let's move on to
some hypothesis class that is less
trivial a hypothesis class of say VC
Dimension D now we know that for
supervised learning we need about D over
Epsilon labeled points if we want
something with error Epsilon okay I'm
leaving out all the log factors and all
that kind of stuff okay so let's follow
exactly the same methodology as before
this is the number of label points we
need let's start with that many
unlabeled points okay and now we know
again from VC theory that if you have
this many unlabeled points the number of
different ways to classify them is D
over Epsilon to the D this is s
LMA and so this is the effective number
of different classifiers that we are
choosing between okay now what we do is
suppose we ask queries that cut our
version space in half every time so what
we do is we find a query X such that
exactly half of the classifiers say it's
plus and the other half say it's minus
and we keep doing this so with each
query once we find out which it is
whether it's plus or minus our version
space gets hared and in this way we need
Only log of this many yeah other
guarantees that such will exist
absolutely not and we'll get to that in
a second this is a fantasy okay but so
you know so if this worked out if we
were able to do this this is sort of the
dream kind of uh situation with be in
which is again this this this amazing
thing where in we would get a classifier
of error Epsilon instead of needing one
over Epsilon we need Only log one over
Epsilon um points yeah but
um but when you have a small class of
hypotheses the sample
complexity some sense grows
logarithmically with the size of that
class do like pack learning right so you
could plug that into the No No the V
Dimension is even better than the the
cardinality of the set it's always the
log of the set is always bigger equal
the VIS Dimension and he's already using
the VIS Dimension
here yeah so the so the problem so the
first problem that Daniel pointed out is
that haling queries might not exist
there might not be any point that
exactly halves the space
yeah yeah so actually so um so that's a
wonderful so so one example of
interaction that I didn't mention is
teaching where uh you have a human that
is actually choosing maximally
informative examples okay so the
situation we're talking about is that a
machine is given a large amount of
unlabeled data and has to figure out
which the informative ones are well if
there's a teacher who actually knows the
concept beforehand that teacher should
be ex you know should be well equipped
to actually pick out those informative
examples at least in principle okay
that's right so that could lead to that
could lead to significantly less uh
complexity okay so for example in the
case of um the line instead of needing
log one over Epsilon you would just need
two examples the teacher gives you a
negative example just on one side of the
threshold and a positive example just on
the other side so we're teaching you
just need two examples and not there' be
no Epsilon in there at all You' get the
great okay so
um another issue with this generic
framework over here is that
um okay so first of all you you know
it's easy to construct instances where
there are no queries that cut the space
in half or even close to it you know
every query is highly biased almost all
the classifiers think it's plus and
there's only a tiny fraction that think
it's minus or vice versa the other thing
is that you know in many cases this D is
a large number and actually juggling a
version space of this size is a
nightmare okay so it's just uh that's
intractable and then also what do you do
when there's zero error okay this has
all been assuming that there's some
perfect
classifier anyway so there's been a lot
of work along this line um and the the
approach to this is saying you know the
approach to the first problem that
harving queries might not exist the
natural approach is okay you don't have
something that exactly halves the space
but just pick whatever comes closest to
doing that okay pick the one that most
nearly does that and that's a greedy
approach and and many variants of that
um have been have been investigated and
especially in cases where the number of
effective hypotheses is not that large
this can be uh super effective okay and
another variant is query by committee
which is doing something similar but
with a basian prior on top of these
hypotheses and that's um also been quite
effective now just mention that there
you know some of the work also addresses
that first question of quantifying
whether or not these having queries are
going to exist given the structure of
the hypothesis space and the structure
of the queries you can make right right
in understanding what are the situations
in which these would yeah in which these
would occur
yeah okay so I'm going to be talking
about three types of active learning
results the first um on which there's
been a lot of work which I'll just call
Mellow Active Learning then a bunch of
htics that are actually closer to what
is typically done in practice where you
sample close to the boundary and then
finally an approach which I think is
very promising in terms of both
combining the sort of theoretical
analyses and being super practical okay
um and so let me see whether I get
through um at least one of these okay so
um so Mello Active Learning the
the this was a scheme that was
introduced in the early '90s by con
Atlas and Ladner and so they consider a
scenario where this unlabeled data is
just coming in one point at a time and
you just have to make these spot
decisions do I want its label or not
okay and then the next Point comes in
and you decide do I want it label or
not and this is a super non-aggressive
scheme basically it asks for the labels
of everything except the things it is
100% certain about okay so if you're
completely sure what the label is don't
ask for it otherwise ask for it okay so
the mellowest possible scheme so um this
is assuming that there is a perfect
classifier in the class okay so your
initial version space is the entire
hypothesis class at each point you
receive a new unlabeled data
point and now if there's any
disagreement within your hypotheses
suppose you have a 100 a th classifiers
left and 999 of them think this point is
plus and one of them thinks it's minus
there's disagreement so you ask for the
label if all 1,000 of them think it's
plus then you don't ask for the label
okay so those are the only points you
don't label
um and so and and you keep going in this
way okay so for example let's say you're
in this situation seven data points have
already come in now the eth point has
arrived and you want to decide whether
you're going to ask for its label well
given the data that you have so far the
candidate hypotheses you have are stuff
like this these are the these are the
classifiers that are still in the
running okay and all of them P this is a
red so you would not ask for its label
so the only points you would ask for are
points that lie in this region of
disagreement over here okay these are
the only ones you would ask about and so
that's the way this scheme works okay so
um so there two comments about this the
first is that over here you don't need
to explicitly maintain the version space
and the reason for this is you just keep
around the label points you've seen so
far when a new Point comes around you
say okay let me try it with a plus label
so you give it a plus label you add it
to the data set and then you call your
classifier you say okay find me a
classifier that's consistent with these
points and you say okay let me try with
a minus label you add it to the data set
you say find me a classified consistent
with these labels so as long as you have
something that does the supervised
learning for you you don't actually need
to maintain this potentially
exponentially large version space okay
so it's it's very
efficient and the second thing is that
it basically ends up with a label for
everything so at time T you have
everybody's label okay um
either you asked for the label or you
filled it in yourself because you were
100% certain what it was okay so nothing
goes on labeled and say that there's no
sampling bias at all okay so this is how
it takes care of sampling bias it just
makes sure everything's labeled
okay now the amazing thing or the
surprising thing about this scheme is I
mean you'd think it wouldn't do very
much because it's not seeking out
informative points it's just seeking out
any point that gives you nonzero
information
okay and yet you can show that it
actually still achieves this kind of log
1 Epsilon dependence uh on the error
rate okay and so this was shown by Steve
hanii so he characterized the label
complexity of this scheme in terms of
the VC Dimension as usual but also in
terms of this other parameter which he
called the disagreement coefficient and
um and which we'll get to in in you know
in in uh in a few minutes okay but the
main thing is that remember this is the
this was the if I if I remove this data
this is sort of the label complexity of
the dream scheme you know when we could
perfectly have and this achieves the
same thing but with this constant in
front with this constant Theta in front
and the dependence on Epsilon is just
logarithmic instead of the usual one
over Epsilon not really it's not really
a constant because it depends on the
marginal
distribution right so it um so it's a in
right it's not a yeah so it's definitely
you know nothing's a constant but um it
it doesn't depend on Epsilon so in terms
of the dependence on Epsilon you really
are getting a log one over Epsilon
dependence which is surprising for a
scheme that's really so mellow okay so
let me explain how this comes around
okay and and by the way this is only for
the case of separable data but this has
been generalized to um the non-separable
case by various subsets of these people
listed
here okay so let me um so let me explain
how this how this happens okay so why
does a simple scheme like this actually
get you a very um such small label
complexity okay so remember that this
method essentially gets everybody's
label okay either fills it in itself or
queries it so after you've seen T points
you have t labels you have t labeled
points which means by VC theory that the
error rate of any consistent classifier
is about
d/t okay after you've seen T points the
error rate is D overt everything
consistent has got an error at most D
overt now the only points you're going
to you're going to query are those which
have a little bit of on which there's
some disagreement so let's say the
disagreement region of the current
version space are those points on which
there's some disagreement and those are
the only ones we're going to query okay
the disagreement coefficient tells us
that this disagreement region is bounded
um can be can be bounded quite easily
okay tells us that the probability mass
of this disagreement region is at most
the error rate d/t times this constant
Theta or this not constant Thea okay
yeah so you're not worried here how to
actually maintain the space how to what
no no no this just the analysis yeah
we're not maintaining the
space so this so we'll get to the
disagreement coefficient in a second but
this is what it gives us it balanced the
probability of this disagreement region
so now let's see the probability of
asking a query at time T you'll only ask
a query if the point Falls in this
disagreement region and the probability
mass of this region which is the
probability of getting a point that you
query is Theta time the error rate at
that time which is Theta * d/ T and when
you sum this overall T then you get
Theta * D * log T okay and how far do
you need to go well if we want error
Epsilon we need to keep going until we
have D over Epsilon points so you plug
in um D over Epsilon over here and
therefore you get this this bound okay
so it's a very simple proof um as long
as um we we manage this deal about the
disagreement region
okay okay so let's look at
um so let's look at the disagreement
coefficient so this explains how we get
the Theta D log D over Epsilon let's
look at the definition of the
disagreement coefficient
and this requires us to get a little bit
into the geometry of the hypothesis
class okay
so we have some data space we have some
Distribution on that
space and this distribution induces a
metric on the hypothesis so if we look
at two classifiers the distance between
them is simply the fraction of data on
which they disagree okay very natural
pseudometric and this gives us a notion
of balls in hypothesis space you you
have say the target classifier the ball
of radius R around the target classifier
is everything that disagrees with it on
at most R fraction of data
okay um so let's look at some examples
let's say we just have a thresholds
along the line these are two classifiers
everything to the right is this
everything to the right is plus
everything to the left is minus this is
another
classifier the distance between them is
the probability Mass is the chance that
they disagree so it's the probability
mass of this interval so that's the
distance between these two
classifiers the ball of radius R around
the target classifier is everything that
disagrees with it on less than R
fraction of points so you look at
probability Mass R to the right
probability Mass R to the left and any
threshold that lies in there is in this
ball B of H Comm R okay so this is sort
of the geometry of the hypothesis
class now the disagreement region is um
consists of um so we have our current
version space and we're looking at what
are the points on which there is some
disagreement now as time goes on the
version space is basically all
hypotheses all classifies are that are
consistent with the data you've seen so
far there are lots of different things
that this version space could be but the
only ones we need to be bothered with
are the ones that are basically balls
around the target classifier okay after
you've seen D over T points we're
looking at a ball of radius D overt
around the target classifier so we only
need to think about version spaces of
this form a ball around the target of
radius R every other version space we're
going to deal with is going to be inside
one of
these okay and so the disagreement
coefficient is the probability of being
in that disagreement region divided by
the error rate okay and so let's look at
let's look go back to our
thresholds
this is the
target um the ball of radius R around it
is all intervals of probability Mass R
to the right a probability Mass R to the
left the disagreement region um so these
are the so we're thinking about
classifiers in here the points on which
they disagree are the points that also
lie within here and so this region the
disagreement region is this red region
over here it has probability Mass to R
and you divide it by R and and so the
disagreement coefficient for thresholds
is just two which means that um when you
run that procedure on um um on data on
the line with thresholds the label
complexity bound is just um 2 * log 1
over
Epsilon
okay so now let's look at a slightly
more
um
um Advanced case which is um
disagreement for linear separator so
actually I'm running a little bit short
on time so I think I'm going to um just
fast forward this part a little bit okay
um just to say that you know this was a
toy example where we were so you know
the we we got a Bound for label
complexity of any hypothesis class in
terms of this disagreement coefficient
and we went through this toy example to
to obtain its disagreement coefficient
um um
but you know you can also do this for
for real concept classes like uh for
like linear
separators okay okay Android you know I
I can go a little fast through my
section too so if you need if you want
to go through it I I can condense it in
mind too so
um that's okay I'll just I'll just you
know I'll move on to the next uh topic
um
okay so
um Okay so so we had this so we started
with this mellow Active Learning which
is this very very simple scheme queries
almost everything and then somehow um
you uh managed to just to get this very
low sample complexity very low label
complexity okay now I think in practice
however um the behavior of these methods
agrees with our intuition that they are
just not aggressive enough okay although
the bounds look very impressive in um in
practice it turns out that they really
are not aggressive enough and that we
need something that um that is really
looking for more informative queries and
so I'm going to talk about two different
types of work
um um and
um so there's one kind of work called
margin based Active Learning and um what
what this does is that it um it looks at
algorithms that are a little for
learning linear separators that are a
little closer to sort of the Practical
heris okay so at any given time you have
some estimate of what you think the
linear separator is and you know the the
sort of schemes that are used in
practice are to query the points that
lie very close to that boundary okay so
what these schemes do is they say well
we aren't going to query the points
absolutely closest to the boundary but
we're going to look at some margin
around
it okay we're going to look at some
margin and we're going to query at
random from this margin okay and uh so
it's schemes that look like this okay
and what is this Marg
margin um in the work that's been done
so far it's the this this margin is a
schedule that is gradually decreasing
with time and Depends heavily on the
underlying distribution and it's only
been analyzed for very special
distributions like the uniform
distribution or log concave
distributions yeah when you chose those
random points is that according to their
distribution the underline distribution
so just additional right but these um um
right so it's with respect to the
underlying distribution but the analysis
has only been done in the case where
this underlying distribution is uniform
or log concave or you know it's not just
the analysis but we know that in other
cases it w't work right so um so what
would be nice is to have a somewhat more
adaptive version of this where um um
where where this margin is found in some
adaptive way and is not fine tuned to
the distribution but um so let me just
quickly give you some of the intuition
for this um
and the sort of the Insight Behind These
methods is the following it's um if you
go back to the
supervised
um uh learning bound of D over Epsilon
you can ask how many examples do you
need to have the error okay so if you
look at this bound you see that if you
want the error to go from 2 Epsilon to
Epsilon the number of examples you need
is something like this
okay so the number of examples you need
to half the error depends on what your
current error rate is at the outset when
you're going from error one to error a
half you need just D examples error a
half to error a quarter just DH examples
okay but later on you start needing more
and more examples to have the error for
the simple reason that most of the
examples are useless they're telling you
stuff you already know okay so the
intuition Behind These methods is to
always stay in the efficient regime
never get yourself to the point where
you need D over Epsilon examples in
order to half the error okay and the way
you do that is just um cut out the
regions that you're sure
about okay when you're getting close to
the boundary cut out the regions you're
sure about and operate in a region where
your error rate is a constant and then
you'll be in this and then you can keep
Haring the error with just D examples so
like that or how do you do that you
synthesiz um no so this so the
Assumption here is that the data
distribution is
uniform so you know so you'll find
plenty of examples in that right okay so
that's the intuition so oh unlabeled
examples there's lots of okay because
it's a uniform distribution so you can
as close as you like to the
Marin
okay okay so um the last type of active
learning that I'll be discussing um is
what might be called active
annotation and this reformulates the
problem a little bit and let let me
explain why okay so the the no the
problem with a lot of the schemes I've
discussed before is that they're really
fine-tuned to the type of classifier
using so imagine how machine learning is
normally done right you get this new
data set and you're like okay I'm going
to um fit a linear classifier to it so
you so you use the special Active
Learning algorithm for linear
classifiers and it queries a small
number of points and you get your
classifier but then you say you know
what this data is not looking very
linear to me I actually did a quadratic
classifier so then you use an active
learning scheme for quadratic
classifiers does it query the same
examples no completely different
examples you completely wasted the stuff
you did before okay and then you get the
quadratic thing and you're happy with it
for one or two months and then you
realize actually I need a neural network
so then you use the active learning
skipe for neural network which queries
another completely different set of
examples okay so um um so another way to
think about the problem another way to
formulate the problem that might be
better in general is what might be
called active annotation so you have
this data set of endpoints you don't
know anybody's label it's all it's the
labels are all missing but you given
some parameters Delta and Epsilon and
you have an article that can supply any
label you want and now you want to fill
in those labels you're going to query
some you're going to infer the rest and
you want to have this guarantee that
almost all the labels are correct so
there's a million unlabeled points you
want to query say a thousand of them
fill in the labels of the rest and have
at most Epsilon fraction of then be
wrong and then you can use the same data
set over and over again with um um with
any um with any classifier that you want
okay does that make
sense so it's kind of a non-parametric
Active Learning okay um and so I'll just
describe one scheme of this form um
which is a very nice scheme um so what
sorry what go back to the formulation
again so what what are you given and
what what's the output so yeah so you're
just all you're given is the data set
yeah okay and maybe some Epsilon Delta
if you like okay and um you return a
labeling of the data
set okay so you query some of the labels
so you have this data set of 100,000 say
unlabeled points you're going to query
some of them right and then you fill in
the other labels in such a way that in
most Epsilon fraction of the labels are
wrong oh you know something about the
hypothesis class that's not on the slide
um there no assumptions about that
there's no assumptions so in the worst
case of course you know but you know if
while you're looking at the data it
turns out to have nice cluster structure
or it turns out to have some other kind
of structure of this form then that's
something that you can potentially
exploit okay so this is a nonparametric
setting non-parametric no assumption
setting and the label complexity will
depend on whatever structural properties
the data actually turns out to have okay
so it's like if it's well clustered then
you get low label otherwise not
right so for example here is a graph
based formulation where you take your
end points and you build a neighborhood
graph on it now everything's got a true
label so let's say the stuff here is
plus and the stuff outside is minus okay
um then you can think of the complexity
of this problem as being the number of
edges the number of cut edges and that's
what you want to find if you can find
the cut edges then you find the two
components um the plus and the minus
okay and so and so you want to ask a few
queries that helps you identify these
cut edges so your concepts are connected
sets connected sets in this graph or
what is the yeah so I so it as a
connected I'm just trying to the um so
the label can be arbitrary so they're
not connected okay um no so it could be
that for example the labels are
completely random in which case the
number of cges is huge and you're
completely you know you're hosed right
or it could be that there's some nice
structure in there in which case the
number of cages is much fewer and so
what you'd like to do is to have a
scheme that kind of scales with that
number right so what would we expect so
let's say you do a little bit of random
sampling and you find a point that's a
plus and a point that's a minus so so
now you know that there's a path that
connects them that includes a cut Edge
just by doing binary search along that
path you can find the cut Edge okay so
you can find each cuted with log
diameter number of queries and so the
total query complexity you would expect
to be something like the number of cutes
Times log diameter something something
of that form right and so um and so let
me describe a really nice scheme of this
form um that's due to um to Rob and his
student got the RT and Jerry U this is
the algorithm this is the whole thing
right here okay so um so here's what you
do right um at each given step you say
are there so initially you have no uh
labels at all and over time you collect
a few labels at any given point you ask
are there two points of opposite label
do I have two points of opposite label
if so look at all shortest Parts
connecting points of opposite label find
the shortest such path and query its
midpoint okay so for example we have
this graph over
here initially I have no labels so I
start with a few random queries until I
get two points of opposite polarity so
now I have this point that's a blue and
this these two points that are whites
that query three points now look for all
shortest paths between points of
opposite label so there's one shortest
path here and one shortest path here
this is the shorter one so query its
midpoint and so the next point you query
is is this one you query its midpoint
okay so now I again have several points
of opposite
polarity this is the next point I query
the midpoint and I've identified one of
the cartes okay and you keep going in
this way until you get all the cartes so
the total time taken is proportional to
the number of cages times some like log
of the kind of path lengths you're
dealing with and that part those path
lengths are in the worst case related to
the diameter of the graph but actually
this is done in a way where it's you're
actually trying to keep those path
lengths short as well
yeah so this kind of reminds me of
Battleship but you can have some little
label up in the left corner randomly
which is a plus everything else is a
minus so how do you make sure you
actually find that yeah so the deal yeah
oh yeah so so if there are okay so let's
say for example there's just a tiny
number of pluses right so then you know
only only like 1% then you need to
sample 100 points in order to get one of
those pluses but also the way in which
the active annotation problem is
formulated you're allowed to screw up
Epsilon fraction of the label
and so that's also another kind of cat
all so basically there is this random
search element that really can't be
overcome if there you know you have to
yeah so here the point is that you
cannot Define you know a set of
hypothesis and then say that I want to
find the best
hypothesis um yeah it's just that the
the different hypotheses you can imagine
a sort of um um you know they different
complexities depending on the number of
edges so it's like sort of a a nesting
of hypothesis classes and you want
to okay okay so um I'm going to move on
now um to so uh so I'm now going to hand
over to Rob uh who is uh who as you can
see has been doing some uh amazing work
on Active Learning but also more
generally in the on many topics uh just
in the general area of adaptive signal
processing you say okay and um yeah and
so he will continue okay great thanks
[Applause]
Z okay so uh Sandro did a great job and
Emma did a great job this
morning
and
actually what I'm going to talk about I
mean I will try to talk about some other
learning problems and structures what I
want to talk about actually is very
related to things Emma talked
about and uh I'll explain why and I'll
get into that a little bit as we go so I
think my mic sounds good uh this is the
active learning story and what I really
wanted to spend a little time on is
talking about how we might go from some
of the theory that that we've heard to
actually working algorithms implemented
on real world problems and trying to
close the gap between theory and
practice so uh one of the motivations
for active learning is to reduce uh the
amount of effort required by human or
group of humans helping train a machine
to uh come up with a good predictive
model but I also want to kind of think
about this other problem Andro mentioned
it too maybe instead of the expense
Being Human effort the expense is uh
experimental budget so maybe we're doing
some biological experiments trying to
develop a good predictive model Based on
data coming from those experiments and
we're going to try to use the machine
that's learning a model also to guide
the selection of experiments to run and
I'll I'll give some examples of of both
of these as we go the general idea is
that if we just did something random or
passive learning we'd have a certain
prediction error as a function of the
number of samples or examples we see the
hope with active learning as that we do
something adaptive we let the samples
that we collect depend on the paths that
we've seen and hopefully that will allow
us to learn a good predictive model with
fewer uh
samples the the problem is is that in a
lot of active learning this adaptivity
uh leads to lots of additional
complicating complexity so not only
complexity in the design and Analysis of
algorithms but complexity in terms of
scalability and computation
complexity in terms of fragility to
modeling assumptions and so forth lots
of things we've heard about and so
because of these types of issues this is
one reason why we haven't seen so much
Active Learning fielded and used
routinely in
practice so uh interactivity can help
these are just a kind of laundry list of
places where people have tried uh and
developed Active Learning methods um and
the kind of current state of affairs is
that promising theory in a lot of these
areas hasn't translated into routine
practice so why is that I've already
kind of mentioned computational burden
perhaps of finding and selecting what
are those best questions to ask those
best samples to collect challenges just
of implementation how do you really do
it in the real world when say you're
working with humans and you have to kind
of almost do things in real time can you
really uh carry this out fragility
issues and then because of some of those
fragility issues and so forth and
modeling assumptions mismodeling a lot
of the theory can end up being overly
conservative we heard that from sanjoy
Emma mentioned it too sometimes the
bounds they're they're really not all
that tight and while they might give us
some insight into how these things are
working they don't really give us kind
of practical usable
algorithms so uh one of the kind
Solutions about how to go about maybe
starting to close some of the gaps
between theory and practice I is to look
at specific cases where we have good
empirical success maybe a decent kind of
amount of theoretical understanding and
then really try to develop practical
algorithms that are robust scalable
accurate and work and and give provably
kind of guaranteed results and so I'm
going to kind of go back to where Emma
started in a lot of her examples I'm
going to think about multiarm Bandits uh
and I'll say a little bit more about why
this is but basically
uh I'm going to look at basic multi-arm
Bandits linear Bandits uh and human
machine interaction applications with
them and the reason I decided to focus
on that originally I thought well I'll
just kind of start to give a laundry
list of things people have tried and
done uh and I felt like I couldn't
really go into much detail and also I
couldn't really say much about
transferring Theory to practice but here
in the context of Bandits I can and why
uh well the analysis and Bounds we have
in a lot of these cases are pretty tight
even though the constant factors aren't
so bad so we really have a not much of a
gap between what happens in theory uh
and what happens in practice and we so
that means we can make algorithms that
basically as aggressive as we can make
them in terms of their adaptivity and
interactivity uh while still
guaranteeing their
performance so I'm not going to talk
about everything under the sun in
Bandits I'll just give a couple of
examples and go through a little bit of
analysis uh Emma did a great job of
talking about some of that and also
about reinforcement learning uh another
source for lots of things on Bandits is
some of Sebastian bck stuff which I
really like especially I was just
looking and PR preparing this over his
summer school lectures from last year
these are very good they're fairly up to
date it was just last May and so those
are are really nice sources and so I'm
going to focus mainly on stochastic
Bandit settings rather than adversarial
settings and things like that so this is
the stochastic Bandit problem again the
idea is we have some set of arms we know
we have n arms but each of those arms
has an unknown reward distribution so P1
through PN these are unknown to us uh
and what we're going to do while we play
this game is we're going to have to
choose an arm at each time step and then
draw a random reward from that arm's
distribution and the goal is to uh
select arms that maximize the expected
reward
okay this leads as we've heard to the
classic tradeoff explore we need to
learn about these unknown distributions
we start off we know nothing so we have
to start exploring to learn about those
distributions but after we've explored a
little bit we see that some arms are
giving us better rewards on average than
others and we like to exploit that if
our goal is to maximize
rewards so here are two examples one is
I think familiar to most people here and
that's like displaying ads so the arms
are ads the actions are which ad to
display when a customer comes to a web
page and the reward is whether or not
they click okay um in a more kind of
scientific case uh this is a situation
where uh something I've worked with
people in Madison on they have uh 13,000
strains of fruit flies each cell strain
is missing a single Gene and they're
trying to figure out which genes are
important in the process of vir how a
virus replicates in a host organism so
each of these St of cells as an arm they
can infect a culture of a particular
strain with a virus and then measure how
much that virus is able to replicate
itself and that virus replication level
is sort of the reward we get on that
experiment and so what they like to do
these there 13,000 strains they have to
grow a little culture of each strain
they have to infect it they have to wait
a while it's expensive timec consuming
they'd like to figure out which genes
are most important in VI replication
with the fewest number of experiments
and you can also formulate this as a
bandit arms are genes actions are which
Gene strains to infect in a new
experiment and then the reward is what
what they observe in terms of virus
replication
okay so uh you know the the the way you
can start thinking about this and Emma
discussed it a bit is we have arms for
each arm the blue dots are our
empirical uh average reward that we've
observed and then we also have a
confidence interval around that average
uh that confidence interval basically
we're saying with large probability the
true mean lies within that
interval uh and those intervals are
basically proportional to one over the
square root of the number of samples
you've taken from that particular
arm
okay um so the more samples we get the
smaller the intervals become and you can
see that if you thought for example of
like the version space idea that sanjoy
was was mentioning if I see that well
I'm pretty confident based on this
confidence interval that the mean of
this arm is somewhere in this range the
true mean but some of these other arms
were very confident that they can't
possibly be as high as that lower Bond
so we could discard those guys trim our
version space if we will and this is one
type of Bandit algorithm it's called
successive reject or successive
elimination okay
um let me just give a little bit of
notation so arms we have n of them each
arm has an expected reward mu1 through
mu n I'll just assume for convenience
that mu1 is the largest so that would be
the the arm that has the highest
expected reward an important parameter
are the gaps Emma mentioned it very
briefly but I'll just kind of Define it
here the Gap uh uh Delta I is the gap
between the largest expected reward
reward and the reward we get from some
other arm M ofi so sort of the the the
Gap in in the reward between the best
one and some suboptimal
arm xit T are random rewards that we
obtain from arm I at time T and then mu
hat i t sub I is just uh the empirical
mean of arm I after we've collected TI
random rewards from
it and so one of the things again was
mentioned briefly you could assume that
your rewards are bounded or that they're
subgaussian then what that means is that
your empirical mean starts to look kind
of like a gaussian distribution around
the true mean and that it's
concentrating very quickly about that
true mean as I if I've taken T samples
then this is concentrating exponentially
quickly with t okay and you can
generalize this it doesn't have to be
bounded or subg it could be
subexponential or other types of uh tail
kinds of bounds on on what you think the
rewards distributions look like but if
you have that then what you can do is
you can get confidence intervals so
here's my true mean the empirical mean
and I'm sort of putting those confidence
uh intervals around that true mean and
the width of that confidence interval is
basically proportional to log log T over
T and the square root of that and I'll
use those kinds of uh confidence
intervals as we go
okay so two problems we could look at
one is well I'll call like a prediction
problem this is just where we're trying
to minimize our regret uh that's just
again the difference between the uh
reward we could get if we play the the
expected reward we get if we always play
the best arm and then we're comparing
that to the expected rewards we get
based on what we actually do play so
that's our regret and if you kind of
just think about this a little bit you
can rewrite quickly and see where these
gaps start to play a role you can
express this regret as a sum over all
the arms the gap of each arm with from
the the best arm and then the expected
number of times you've actually sampled
that suboptimal arm okay so the gaps
show up right there and what this is
saying is we want to maximize the Clicks
in this web advertising problem or we
want to maximize the total virus
replication that we see in our
experiments so maybe um if you were
doing something else and you're trying
to maybe get organisms to produce
something like a fuel or something maybe
this would be a great model for that
you'd like to maximize through
experimentation how much fuel or
whatever you can do uh have those
organisms produce actually aren't you
minimizing the number of misclicks and
minimizing sort of M replication by
using
regret so uh we're we're just trying so
what you're trying to do is select the
arm that makes it most probable that
somebody's going to click on it so
maximizing the probability that somebody
will click is the same as minimizing
this
regret um the other problem uh that you
could think about in this context is
more of a model selection problem where
you're not just trying to you know
maximize your rewards but you're
actually trying to identify which arm is
that arm with giving you the largest
reward and so here you'd like to do
something more like pure exploration
maybe choose a sequence of arms in order
to just kind of identify as quickly as
possible which arm is the best average
reward so identify the arm that
maximizes expected clicks or that
maximizes virus replication which would
be in that virus replication example
identifying the gene that is most
important in the virus rep replication
process okay so why why again let me
come back to the issue why I'm talking
again about Bandits so the important
thing is is that near optimal algorithms
exist for these problems and not only
are they order optimal but the constants
are actually pretty good so we have a
very very small gap between what we
understand theoretically and what we
actually observe empirically and through
simulation so this is uh an algorithm
again Emma mention it upper confidence
bound algorithm that's based on the of
uh turistic of optimism in the face of
uncertainty so the idea is that here I'm
showing you the arms uh and at each step
of this process you're going to sample
the arm that has the largest upper
confidence bound and if you do that what
happens is it basically tends to
equalize all these upper confidence
bounds and in doing that you end up
really focusing on arms with higher
means and shrinking those confidence
intervals much more than others down
here I'm just plotting the number of
times each arm has been sampled and you
can see just by virtue of this process
and maybe I can run it again what
happens is you just you start off
initially sampling more or less at
random but correctly over time you start
focusing on arms with higher
payoffs and it turns out this strategy
is basically managing both exploration
and exploitation in a really nice way
okay so let me go back to this
so one of the things that you could kind
of convince yourself of if you think
about this a little bit is eventually
this kind of algorithm is going to stop
sampling suboptimal arms as long as
there's some gap between the highest
mean and the second highest mean what's
going to happen is eventually you can't
shrink this guy as long as these are all
valid confidence intervals once this guy
gets shrunk far enough he's separating
from all the others and you'll stop
sampling all the others yeah is this
changing if the distributions of the SS
are changing as well for example is now
the best one Chang did you just repeat
that I'm sorry if the
distributions changing if the
distributions are changing over time
yes so here I'm assuming that the
distributions are fixed and you're
getting independent and identically
distributed samples every time you
sample from a given arm so those
distributions are not varying over time
in this setup yes this does mean that
there's some probability that the
optimal arm only get sampled fin thatly
many times yeah so uh when I say
eventually we'll stop sampling that's
with large probability that you specify
ahead of time so say you want to say I
want to be 99% confident that nothing
goes wrong in this procedure uh these
would all be kind of under the caveat of
with some high large probability that
you decide on ahead of time um for
example literally just sampling the the
one with the largest upper bound how do
you how do you parameterize that
algorithm uh well let maybe I maybe
that'll become clear in a slide or two
if you just give me a second if not then
let's come back to that so um what can
you say about this UCB style algorithm
basically you say that in terms of
regret the regret basically behaves at
at time capital T after capital T
samples they regret something like some
of the inverse gaps some of those Delta
I one over them uh time log
t uh and in terms of selecting the best
arm and I'll go through this a little
bit to explain where it comes from in a
minute you can find the top arm in
capital T samples where tap capital T
grows roughly like the sum of the
inverse Gap squared uh times a log log
factor and I'll explain that in a minute
but both of these
uh upper bounds are essentially tight
and even the constants are small as I
said so there's not a
huge amount of R wiggle room unlike some
of the other problems that we love to
solve that I think are great open
challenges how to make things like
high-dimensional linear classifiers work
actively and provably good that's
something I don't feel like we're there
yet okay so let me just kind of quickly
explain maybe this will help clarify
things a little bit for Daniel so the
idea is that
that uh here are my confidence intervals
and they're basically of the form again
something like log log t/ T in the
square root so that's the width of the
confidence interval and this Delta this
is my confidence that all these things
are holding true okay so you can choose
that as you like in this setup so take
Delta to be 1% so there's a 1% chance
that things
fail this is our upper confidence Bound
for armi it's the empirical mean Plus
that half width of the confidence
interval uh and and here's the the
simple idea to get a little bit of sense
of why these algorithms work so we're
going to the the algorithm samples the
the arm with the largest upper
competence bound so armi is sampled only
if its upper confidence bound which is
this is greater than the corresponding
upper confidence bound of arm one which
is the one that we are assuming in this
analysis to have the largest imper the
largest true mean
okay so the picture looks like this this
guy's upper confidence bound is a little
higher so we're going to sample him
instead of that
one now uh if we assume that these
confidence intervals are
valid uh and that arm I was sampled to
Capital TI time so far what we know is
that the upper confidence Bound for one
has to be larger than its mean and the
upper confidence Bound for arm I has to
be less than its mean plus the full
width of that confidence confence
interval so what I'm saying here is just
I'm saying like in kind of a worst case
situation this guy's mean is right up
hitting at the border there and this
guy's mean is way down here but we know
both of them have to be if these are
valid the true means have to be in those
intervals and so we could have this kind
of inequality going and if we then just
arrange that inequality and move the mui
over to the other side where it tells us
as the Gap Delta I has to be less than
or equal to the full width of the
confidence interval for
RI okay so us to be one just be greater
than mu1 minus it's lower bound why is
minus this guy yeah I'm just saying that
he could be anywhere so I'll put him
right at the top of his right so this
mu1 is somewhere in this interval so the
biggest T could be is right at the top
mui is somewhere in this interval so the
smallest T could be is right at the
bottom and that's all I'm saying and
then I'm saying if we're in the
situation where we're going to sample
RMI it must be that this upper
confidence bound exceeds this one and
that gives us this
inequality and
so where I should say where this comes
from a little bit as kind of the law of
the iterated logarithm if you're
wondering where that log log comes from
it has to be there uh it's not just an
artifact of some looseness in analysis
and if you invert that then you
basically get this kind of
bound on the number of times you'll ever
sample a suboptimal RI it's going to be
on the order of one over the inverse
gaps or the inverse Gap squared and then
log log of that inverse Gap
squar okay so that and so this is
basically saying like if we just follow
this simple
strategy with large probability we're
going to eventually stop sampling
suboptimal arms and so we're going to
home in on on the top yeah a so the log
logs are to make sure that with oneus
Delta probability the cont interval is
all the cont so right now I'm just sort
of thinking of
uh so no if we did really want to have
them all be truly simultaneously valid
we'd have to have an extra n in here for
a union bound over all those the sorry
all the the yeah this is just for the I
guy alone in isolation it would look
something like this and this log log is
there because you don't know essentially
it's there because you don't know how
big that Gap is and so you really have
to suffer that extra log log Factor
because of that unknown width of the Gap
Delta okay so that I hope is simple
enough and and convinces you that this
simple algorithm should work well uh
what it basically tells us is that the
UCB algorithm the total number of times
we sample suboptimal arms grows like sum
of the inverse G squared and just to
kind of do something silly not that I
recommend this this but you could say
well let's instead of doing anything
active or wait J question go back one
slide sorry yeah but the the log log
part I mean you can just use hting
inequality to get just log tier of a
Delta right you're just this is a
tighter slightly tighter bound I mean
you could have replaced that with
just and and that is true that still
holds the still holds this
is you if you you would might wonder if
I even need anything up here right if I
could just have log 1 over Delta or
something but you do need something
there and that you do need so yeah this
is sharper up in terms of the order
dependence on T how you how you justify
not taking into account the need for
Union bound over all other arms so
that's a great question and I'm not
going to get into it but basically this
algorithm that we use and I'll show you
it in action in a minute we don't try to
actually have control over all the arms
confidence intervals what we do is we
try to control just two variables the
confidence interval for the top arm and
then we try to control a random variable
which is equal to the total sum of the
number of times you play suboptimal arms
and then we have a random stopping time
based on the number of times you've
pulled arms so we kind of foro in in at
least the the nicest Theory we we don't
need to Union bound over all the arms
and if you want we can chat about that
afterwards yeah you give me an intuition
if I would just take the highest mean it
would work right I need to get
confidence into if you just took the
highest mean it wouldn't work you need
to take the conf Z yeah yeah why why
uh uh I'm not sure if I have a quick
answer for that off the top of my head
um maybe somebody else does or yeah
because there's a there there's a bad
probability event that the guy that is
the top arm accidentally looks a lot
lower and then stays there forever so
the what it what you sampled for him is
below the interval for anybody else and
they just stay within their interval
forever something like that could happen
uh I mean there are other strategies so
I don't want to say that this is the
only strategy you could use the other
one is this successive elimination or
something uh but yeah this one works
well in practice uh yeah thanks it's not
my idea but we we did some extra
analysis to try to tighten up the bounds
as much as we could and get things to
work in
practice is the probability you end up
with the wrong one the probability that
you would end up with the wrong one in
this kind of situation when you go if
you if your goal is to find the arm that
has the highest empirical mean the
failure probability would be this value
Delta which you choose ahead of time
oh or proportional to Delta w't get
large you have a million villion
arms Delta per no uh well let's talk
about it
afterwards is that
let me so so quickly I was just about to
say what if we just did something naive
like sample non-adaptively which means
essentially sample every arm equally
often we could do that and eventually
we'll also shrink these confidence
intervals and be able to figure out
which one's best but if you think about
how many times you're going to need to
sample there you have to sample every
arm essentially as many times as you
have to sample the second best to
separate it from the best which is one
over the smallest Gap squared and so the
total number of samples for a
non-adaptive procedure would be n the
number of arms times the inverse of the
smallest Gap squared and so if the
smallest Gap is small and all the others
are large you might be as much as a
factor of n off of what you could do
with the
Bandit okay so one of the things we want
to do and I I don't know how much time
I'll have but I'll just say this this is
a long running experiment that we've
done to actually test out how do these
algorithms work in practice we've used
this experimental collaboration also to
evaluate and improve algorithms both in
theory and in practice and this is
something we're doing with Bob manov the
cartoon editor from The New Yorker so
the basic idea is that every week 5,000
captions are submitted so there's a
cartoon published without a caption and
readers are invited to try to submit a
funny caption they get about 5,000
entries to this con contest every week
we then crowdsource the rating of these
submissions to a set of volunteers who
provide
ratings for captions and the goal is to
identify which one's funniest to choose
a winner in this contest and we've got
over a year now of of experiments and
each week we're running these banded
algorithms with real humans to see how
they work um this is what it looks like
in the New Yorker page I don't know if
I'm on the internet here I guess I
am uh maybe I shouldn't have done this
but here it is this is this week's
caption contest and basically the idea
is when you come to the system you can
you're using a three star rating process
do you think this is unfunny somewhat
funny and funny the user or volunteer
then clicks what they think and now this
Bandit selects another caption that was
submitted uh adaptively and tries to
collect a rating okay let me close that
and see if I can get back to this talk
quickly shouldn't have done
that what did I
do well that's your out did I close
mine oh there yeah sorry okay so this is
what it looks like this is one actual
contest where there was about 4,000 a
little more than 4,000 submissions these
are the total number of times each
caption has been rated you can see that
initially the ratings are more or less
uniformly random but over time we start
focusing on those that are receiving
higher ratings these are the average
ratings that we're receiving and there's
a very little gap between theory and
practice in this problem it's working
very well I'll just quickly flash up
some analysis we've done where we've
actually taken a large number of ratings
figured out what is the funniest caption
and then repeated uh the banded
algorithms and then just a conventional
crowd sourcing which is non-adaptive and
we see that we get about uh a five times
uh 5x Improvement in terms of how many
samples we need to get a pretty good
sense of what are the top captions so
that's pretty
significant quickly I'll just say a
little bit about structured Bandits so
this is kind of taking it a little bit
further we start off with the very
simplest Interactive Learning problem
now we get a little more complicated
there are a lot of varieties of
structured Bandits we've heard a little
bit about some of them linear Bandits
combinatorial Bandits lipshits Bandits
contextual Bandits I'm just going to say
a little bit about oops about linear
Bandits because they have a nice applic
they have nice applications and they
have a nice Theory that also kind of
just follows along from what we've been
talking about I'll quickly go through
that so the idea is we have arms now of
our Bandit but each arm is associated
with some added side information in the
form of a feature Vector okay so our
arms are vectors in
Rd we have a reward Vector Theta star
and the rewards that we actually receive
are going to be in products between the
feature Vector for the arm that we
select and this waiting given by Theta
Star Plus a little noise so why is our
reward so features that are more well
aligned with this Theta star get higher
rewards on
average the optimal arm would be the one
that gives you the largest expected
reward that's just this and I'm showing
him
here uh and the regret we're going to
look at is the difference between the
expected reward we get if we played this
optimal arm all the time versus the
expected value of the rewards we receive
by playing the arms we select along the
way the uh one way to tackle these
problems is with the same idea this
optimism in the face of uncertainty in
this set setting what we're going to do
is try to construct a confidence set CT
so so that at every time T Theta star
belongs to that confidence set and this
is done uh in a number of papers the the
kind of approach I'm going to talk about
here the bound going to give is from the
last paper that 2011 there so the basic
idea to kind of figure out what this
confidence set is is you just form
essentially
the Le squares or Ridge regression
estimate of theta given the data that
you've collected so far so you've chosen
some arms you know what those are you
see the rewards you use those arms and
rewards to construct an estimate of what
you think Theta looks like that's called
Theta hat uh and if Lambda is small here
this little regularization parameter if
it's a small value then basically this
first part is is about Theta star and
the rest is this stochastic term
here and you can kind of just rearrange
that so now Theta star is like Theta hat
plus a little err and using some Martin
Gale concentration techniques and so
forth what you can do is you can get a
confidence ellipsoid that's that set
that I'm showing there in Gray it's
basically a weight or interner product
of the distance from Theta hat and then
you have a width that depends on the
dimension of the problem d uh the number
of time steps you've taken t and a
little bit on the regularization
parameter and then again you see your
confidence parameter
Delta so the optimism in the face of
uncertainty is the same idea again we're
going to say okay well let's find an
upper competence bomb for each arm how
do we do that well we take each arm say
the E arm and we say what is the best
possible expected reward I could hope to
get if I know that I'm somewhere in here
so you maximize over Theta that gives
you an upper bound on what the expected
reward could be for arm I and then at
each time step you just sample the arm
with the highest upper confidence bound
this is uh the
algorithm so this is the double
maximization that you perform each time
to choose which arm to decide which arm
to sample it turns out that you can
simplify that inner optimization over
Theta because this is just an
ellipsoidal set that ends up looking
like this and if you inspect this then
you see exactly two terms one that's the
exploit term try to choose an arm that
matches where you think Theta is
and then this term which is basically
looking at something like the sample
covariance here and saying explore in
directions you haven't looked so much so
far okay and you have regret bounds that
are problem independent you have problem
dependent ones that involve something
like a gap again uh and these are also
near optimal in terms of the order of
dependence on Dimension and time and so
forth so let me just kind of give a
quick example so I you know I basically
spent a little time looking around what
are the best algorithms for linear
Bandits the these are among those and
then we try to see how well they work in
a real problem so this is sort of an
interactive in image search problem so
the traditional image search problem
would be I give user gives an initial
Target image that goes to the system and
the database and the Machine tries to
retrieve similar
examples the interactive version of this
is that the machine retrieves examples
but after each example the person in
indicates whether or not it was really
matching what they like so maybe they
weren't just interested in tall boots
but they really wanted red boots or
maybe red wasn't so important in another
case it was some other feature that they
were attending to and focusing on so
this kind of feedback allows the system
to potentially R improve the retrievals
in this image search so uh this is a
data set people use for this sort of
thing this is the zapo data set 50,000
shoe images large variety of styles uh
we we featued each of them using deep
learning features so we end up with
about a thousand dimensional feature
Vector for each shoe that's our those
are our x's and our linear
Bandit uh then we had human subjects we
sort of primed them we said you want to
pick out red boots we start this system
off they can say is this a good match to
a red boot or not we tried different
targets different experiments of this
form one of the challenges is that when
a person is doing this this has to be
happening basically in real time and
even you know one pass of that algorithm
requires a search over the whole
database so that's 50,000 images in this
case so it's not non-trivial even to
implement these algorithms in real time
and so we have a bunch of approximation
algorithms for
this with some theoretical guarantees
but again now will they really work in
practice or when you go through all that
stuff do you get something that doesn't
work any better than something simple
like a nearest neighbor non-adaptive
thing so we we wanted to test this and
so here are some results they're kind of
typical of what we saw the green
Baseline here is just nearest neighbor
retrievals the colored curves above are
all the different varieties of uh Bandit
approximations that we developed and
what you can kind of see from this is
that the linear Bandits are retrieving
two to three times as many
relevant uh items as just the the
non-adaptive approach so there working
reasonably well in practice working well
enough to make it worth doing something
like this because there's a lot of
overhead and getting this going and in
the last two minutes that's what I want
to talk about how do you what is the
overhead involved and how do you do it
and this is one of the barriers I think
that's been there between transferring
Theory to practice is that it's just
very very difficult to even do an
experiment like that so uh there are a
lot of practical challenges I've already
mentioned them data management issues
real-time Computing issues why is that a
problem well researchers aren't easy
aren't able to easily feel and test
Interactive Learning algorithms
theoreticians might not really be
working on the right problems because we
don't know really what's going to come
up in practice so there could be really
cool challenges that come up when you
start to try to do these things in the
real world that have interesting
mathematical Solutions and then just
routine practitioners who aren't
necessarily algorithm developers or
Theory provs can't even use these things
because there's no infrastructure to
support it so people have tried to
change that problem and one effort is
Microsoft's multiworld testing decision
service another is something we started
at Madison called Next I don't know
maybe I I won't say too much about these
but I will put in a little plug uh
because it's tea time uh and what I hope
to do during the interactive Workshop
which is in a few weeks in February is
have Alec agraval who has been really
involved in microsofts effort and Kevin
Jameson and lot Jane who are both here
who are two students who really
spearheaded the project at Madison maybe
we'll carve out an hour or something
where we can hear from both of those
groups a little bit about how to how
these systems can be used how they can
facilitate real world experimentation
with active learning algorithms and I
think I'll just stop
[Applause]
there so there was very little uh
discussion about the noise the noise
yeah so whatever I mean you have these
active learning algorithms well when the
response is noisy what do you do yeah so
I mean of course in these Bandits we're
accounting for the noise for example in
the cartoon caption rating contest we
know that the ratings are either 012 say
already have a two three star scale or
whatever and so we know something about
what the largest variability could be in
the empirical process of collecting
ratings for for a given caption we use
that information then to construct these
confidence intervals we were just using
the fact that basically they were
subgaussian and kind of like a huting
type bound was the starting point but
you can do a little bit better than that
using things like KL derive goack lier
Divergence type bounds and you get even
better performance but yeah so we we we
kind of try to make minimal assumptions
about the noise if we know things are
founded that's one starting point we we
can get put some sort of limits on how
noisy things could be if you will so the
S was basically you ask the user yeah
the user might not help yeah so uh that
is a noise yeah so imagine we have one
cartoon caption that we wanted to get
ratings from we all won't agree some
people think it's funny some people
think it's not but if we imagine that
the ground Truth rating was what we all
said but now I just ask a random sub
sample of 10 now I have an empirical
estimate of that that ground truth mean
that's the ensemble mean that that comes
from all of us rating it and so
uh so I mean that that is where the
noise is coming from just variability in
people's responses and that's what we're
trying to account for does that help
yeah that helps but it's more than
that well maybe we can chat more at the
break okay well thank you
you